no forget it when I went to the Emmys
that night nobody knew I was there
right nobody Lois Kane is my publicist
is back there him and Dawn - executive
producer did a great job of keeping that
secret for two months
right no wonder you were showing up and
when I went back there I came back it
was like on my way to the stage
everybody was looking at me like these
short ghosts didn't Lewis said Trey
they're latina and I walked and she had
her back to me I said tape and she
turned around and lost it Wow and I said
Tina I'll see you you got a consumer's
get wrinkled present at the end and I
said Tina she just grabbed me start
crying so Tina stop I'll see you after
you get off
I remember I was dead did that joke yeah
Tina velak down Tina was in the front
row and I see Tina's it was in our heart
she started crying I said the joke she
was happy that the comedy was still
there now I said Lauren I'm gonna come
home and he said train without blinking
he said doors always open
that's right week later I got October
17th October 17th when you went on
Saturday Night Live I went home I was in
there to pitch me in and this young cast
all of them Keenen legs all of them
everybody the cast whole cast was doing
I know they were doing it hardest pitch
the best pitches and they inspired me so
much all men I'm way after I left the
pitch me and I went to the cellar and I
grabbed the mic for the first time for
the very first time it was like a new
life and I did five minutes you mean
because you got so inspired by the pitch
a tonight lot of cash yeah I guess I'll
always be indebted to that cast for
inspiring me to go back and be funny